public markets were taking a beating
when forbes finalized the world
billionaires list on march 18 2020. the
s p
500 cratered 29 from its february 19th
high
while the world ground to a coveted
imposed halt
companies like airbnb and warner music
group who had planned much anticipated
ipos in 2020
sought shelter from the storm instead
things couldn't be more different this
year
after a strong rebound in the second
half of 2020 that has continued into
public markets are booming and plenty of
entrepreneurs are getting in on the
action
among the record 493 new billionaires on
this year's list
forbes found at least 60 who have joined
the list thanks to ipos
over the past year 1489 public offerings
raised 314 billion dollars globally
up from 1239 ipos and 234 billion
dollars in the previous year
big names like food delivery company
doordash went public in december
turning its co-founder and chief
executive tony hsu
and his two co-founders into
billionaires women-centric dating app
bumble went public on the nasdaq in
february
the ipo made bumble's co-founder and ceo
whitney wolfherd
the world's youngest self-made female
billionaire at the age of 31
with a current net worth of 1.1 billion
dollars
bang the founder of music label and
agency hype corp
which represents the popular k-pop band
bts
is currently worth 3.1 billion dollars
he took the company previously known as
big hit entertainment
public on the korea exchange in october
two months before the ipo
bts became the first korean band to top
the billboard hot 100 with dynamite
their first song entirely in english
you